what would happen if you got nine hours of sleep
for seven days in a row let's talk about that so
i've been doing a lot of videos on sleep um
for quite some time and then it dawned on me
i only get about six and a half hours of sleep
so i wanted to do an experiment with myself
so i started to get nine hours of sleep but
first let's talk about what happens when you get
not enough sleep poor sleep and i'm not just
talking about not enough hours of sleep i'm
talking about the quality of sleep as well well
if you get poor sleep your immune system is going
to be affected you're going to be more susceptible
to getting sick okay even infections your risk for
heart attacks and stroke are going to go up you're
going to have altered blood sugars where you're
going to be more hungry and you're going to crave
things because when you don't get enough sleep
that spikes cortisol and that alters your blood
sugars and if you're already a diabetic it's
going to make things worse it's going to affect
your cognitive function in focus concentration
and memory it's definitely going to affect your
mood you're going to feel more irritable it can
also increase your stress level your tolerance
for certain people it's going to be lower and
you're going to gain more weight because most of
the fat burning is at night and growth hormone is
mainly activated at night and growth hormone
is the main fat burning hormone all right so
let me just talk about what's happening with me
um with this nine hours of sleep and it's quite
incredible i love it and i i'm gonna continue this
because normally my neck is very stiff i have a
lot of arthritis in my neck for mold injuries now
it's completely loosened up i don't hear any more
grinding i don't have any more inflammation in my
neck i have more flexibility very interesting the
next thing i want to talk about is my mood
it's definitely higher for sure i have more
tolerance to stress i'm just more up which is very
another interesting point the next point is i have
way more focus and more concentration when i don't
get enough sleep and i'm doing these videos i'm
doing a lot more editing okay now i do a lot less
editing because i'm just right there right there
i'm just sharper very distinct difference in my
cognitive function next thing is i'm not hungry
hardly at all i notice when i don't get enough
sleep i'm more hungry during the day because
my blood sugars are affected the next thing i
want to mention is my endurance with exercise
walking up a hill when i don't get enough sleep i
definitely don't have the endurance now i seem to
have an unlimited amount of endurance i don't get
tired and the last point is i'm getting much much
better recovery from my workouts so i just don't
have that soreness i bounce back faster and i feel
that there's just much much better recovery going
on in my body now here's the thing for years i've
been getting up at like 4 or 4 30. you know so
i'd be getting about six hours and i would usually
take a nap but at the very most i would get about
six and a half hours and of course for years
i got so much more done than the average person
because if you're up at 4 30 and you're doing
all this research and doing videos that's a lot
of extra time compared to the average person
now that i'm sleeping longer i like the way
that i feel compared to the six and a half hours
the problem is it's very difficult for me
to sleep past six and a half hours so i've
been training my body to get more sleep and i'm
going to tell you kind of what i've been doing
so first of all i'm in bed by 9 30 okay i'll
take my friendly bacteria probiotic i'll take
one capful of this okay and just it helps me sleep
okay and i will take one magnesium lactate okay
this is standard process you can use other types
of magnesium and i'll take three of my sleep aid
okay that combination seems to really help me
because when i wasn't taking those i would wake up
at two three maybe four and i just had a hard time
getting back to bed so this combination seems to
be helping because now this puts me out real fast
i'll wake up at 2 30 maybe 3 30 and then i'll lay
there for about 15 minutes and i can go right back
to bed now at first what was happening the first
half of my sleep was pretty good but the last
50 of my sleep i would have to kind of go into
a rem sleep okay which is a superficial sleep very
similar to uh feeling awake and then kind of pop
out of it and then later for a while go back into
a rem sleep for a little bit pop back out and then
go back one more time so i was going through
this cycle of three times waking up going back
waking up going back waking up so the combination
nutrition is helping to the point where i just get
up once and i can go back to bed and i'm finding
the more i do this the easier it is because i'm
training my body to stay in bed until i actually
achieve like nine hours of sleep now the other
thing that i found is i have to exercise one hour
a day because if i don't i have so much energy my
body is just not tired so i have to physically
do a lot to get my body tired so i'll do a
combination of compound resistant type exercise
and i will also do um some high intensity interval
training mix in with that every single day so
anyway i wanted to share this whole sleep thing
because i'm really digging this extra sleep and
i never really actually would realize this until
i actually went through it because now i have
something to compare it to and i feel much better
with more sleep and so i'm going to stick with it
hey before you go if you're benefiting from any of
my content i would love to hear about your success
story please share it in the link down below